et bagages au canapé puisqu'on est bien
confortablement installés moi je vous
propose de nous confiner intelligemment
alors en ou dépendants avec toute la
famille avec un film de circonstance
alexandre le bienheureux de vivre robert
alors pour un grand nombre d'entre vous
c'est un film que vous connaissez déjà
c'est un film avec jean yanne et marlène
jobert principalement c'est un film qui
raconte l'histoire d'un homme à la
campagne qui est poussé au travail
harcelé de travail par sa femme qui est
dit la grande une très bonne femme jouée
par françoise briand et à jour malheur
cette femme meurt dans un accident de
voiture terrible et alexandre se
retrouve à pouvoir accomplir le destin
qu'ils règlent accomplir depuis toujours
se confiner dans sa chambre et attendre
attendre que le temps passe et organiser
sa vie sans rien faire ce qui met
évidemment la totalité de la société du
village en ébullition alors jean
raconterai pas plus c'est ça le pitch
principal mais c'est un film absolument
délicieux et tous une première partie
qui est très dur l'est très très drôle
très comique les enfants adorent faut
vous qu'il n'avait jamais vu adultes
adorerait aussi parce que c'est vraiment
très très piquant et puis là toute la
dernière partie c'est vraiment une
réflexion très très belle sur bas
justement sur la société qu'est ce que
c'est qu'avoir un rôle dans la société à
quoi ça sert de faire fonctionner une
société pourquoi on fait fonctionner
société et est ce qu'on a le droit de ne
pas vouloir faire fonctionner cette
société voilà donc c'était alexandre le
bienheureux de yves robert